All right.
Welcome everyone.
Thanks for joining during your
lunch break and over VC. Um,
I'm really excited to
introduce my research Rober.
She's a Stanford professor and author
who is here to share some really great
tips on how to juggle your work
life and your home life. Um,
I'm going to jump right in because we're
a few minutes behind and she's going to
read an excerpt from one of her books
and go over some slides and answer any
questions that you may have.
So myra is a labor economist
and the professor and at
the School of Education at
Stanford University.
She is also the professor of economics
at the Graduate School of business at
Stanford University.
Her research and consulting
focus on gender issues at
the workplace and work and
family. She is the author of numerous
articles on occupational segregation,
women in the professions and management,
the economics of childcare,
feminist economics and
the teaching of economics.
She was the founding director of the
Michelle are Clayman Institute for Gender
Research at Stanford and she was also
the first chair of the National Council
for Research on women, a consortium
of US Centers for research on women,
which today has more than
100 members centers. Um,
over the year is Myra has consulted with
several corporations on improved that
utilization of women in management
and unwork family issues.
She has also been an expert witness in
cases involving the valuation of work in
the home,
sex discrimination and sexual harassment.
So with that I'll have you take it away.
Great.
Thank you.
Hello everyone.
I'm going to start by
reading from my memoir,
which was published recently by MIT
press and it's called sharing the work.
So I'm going to read from the
very beginning of the memoir.
Then I'll talk a little bit about how
partners can balance family and careers
and then we'll take questions
you'll be able to tell in just a minute.
When this takes place,
it's because you live in Palo Alto.
The chairman of Berkeley's Economics
Department tells me I can't have a regular
job here because I live in Palo Alto.
He nods.
Chairman break is tall with football
players shoulders and although I'm tall to
his massive frame towers over me,
he's the big shot in one of the most
prestigious economics departments in the
country.
I'm the assistant professor want to be.
If this meeting doesn't go well,
he could decide not to hire me for
next year under my jacket reveal of
perspiration, I'm making their way
down my dress for success blouse,
you have to live in Berkeley to be
on your tenure track again. He nods.
I'm baffled. I never
knew that. My husband,
Sam is a medical resident at Stanford
and works incredibly long hours.
Often he goes back to his lab late
at night to check on his experiments.
We have to live in Palo Alto.
Okay.
I say softly getting up to leave.
Thanks very much.
When I get to my office,
my hands are shaking.
I can hardly insert my key into the lock.
I feel drained,
disoriented. Did I take something out
of my freezer for tonight's dinner?
Lamb chops, hamburger,
I dial home, but Margie,
my babysitter doesn't pick up. She's
probably taken the kids out somewhere.
I leave my office and walk across
Sproul Plaza, surprisingly quiet.
After all the years of
student demonstrations,
it's 1970 and the Vietnam war
is beginning to wind down.
I slide into my full size blue Chevy
with a trunk large enough to hold both a
stroller and a carriage and
review my meeting with break.
I spend a lot of time
in big blue these days.
It's about an hour between Palo Alto in
Berkeley in the morning and longer in
the late afternoon and I do
the commute three days a week.
Gradually crawling and stop and go.
Traffic toward the bay bridge.
The absurdity of breaks.
Answer registers.
My first response is to cry.
I grew up around in my purse,
pull out some tissue and Dab at my eyes,
but now the road is blurry.
I switched my thoughts to my
children. Mommy, mommy, Jason.
My three year old will scream with delight
when he hears my key in the lock and
Liz 11 months will follow his lead.
She'll speed across the
living room on all fours,
tug on my leg and make joyful noises.
Suddenly the traffic starts to move.
I can never tell why the snarls dissolve,
but I'm always grateful as
I drive at normal speed,
my thoughts turned back to break,
but this time instead of tears,
I'm aware of growing anger at myself.
What's wrong with you? I scream inside
my head. You let him intimidate you.
You let him make you mute.
You're a smart woman and you
let him make you look stupid.
Faculty don't have to live in
Berkeley to be on the tenure track.
He fed you pure bull and you bought it.
You want to know why you can't have
a tenure track job at Berkeley?
Look at what's real.
There are no women except Margaret and
the whole economics department faculty
and although she's been there for more
than 20 years, she's still a lecturer.
Wake up.
The difference between a lecturer and
an assistant professor is monumental.
Assistant professors have a regular job
with an opportunity for promotion and
lifetime tenure.
Lecturers on the other hand
are on a road to nowhere.
They are appointed from year to year,
generally only a few months before
they're teaching is to begin and have no
chance of advancing.
I've worked too hard for too many
years to be content with second class
citizenship.
I intend to get the real deal at Berkeley.
When I finally get onto the bay bridge,
my anger changes.
Now I'm furious with break dairy.
Tell me I have to live in Berkeley.
The radio was tuned to a talk station
and I registered Joe Carcione,
the popular green grocer instructing
the whole bay area about choosing
Pumpkin's. Ah, Halloween is coming.
Maybe I should revisit breaks,
office and costume.
Which skeleton?
Big Bird.
Surely some costume could
shake him out of his.
We all have to live in Berkeley routine
with my sheets,
skirt and matching man tailored jacket.
I'm wearing stockings and high heels.
The stockings feel sticky and the
shoes pinch every time I accelerate.
How I would love to kick off those shoes.
Whoever invented high heels definitely
didn't have driving in mind.
I'm getting angry by the
second at the traffic,
which has snarled again at my gluey
stockings and to tide high heels and it my
own naive tay.
But most of all I'm angry at brake.
Slowly I begin to understand what people
mean when they say their anger makes
them see red because of swelling.
Fury,
a deep scarlet anger now floods the car,
the steel frame and glass windows can't
contain it and it bursts onto the road
like a flaming oil slick,
a torrent sliding over the bridges,
girders and thundering across the bay.
As the lights of San Francisco began
to flicker against the darkening sky,
I feel a flicker of light within myself.
I become a feminist on the bay bridge.
So the followup to that story is
the morning afterwards I called breaks
office again and asked for another
appointment and his secretary
told me he was very busy.
It would be several weeks
before he could see me. So
I had a second meeting several weeks
later and I asked him the same question
again
and he asked me if I wanted him to
be frank and I said, yes, I did.
And basically he told me that they knew
that I had both a three year old and an
infant and that they didn't know
what was going to happen to me.
I said,
happened to me,
what do you think's going to happen to
me if you give me a position in six years
I'll come up for tenure and promotion
and we'll all see what happens to me.
He said, no. He said, I could
never sell that to the department.
Well, in the meantime,
having nothing to do with me,
the women faculty at Berkeley filed a
complaint with the Labor Department under
a new executive order and investigators
from the Labor Department came to
Berkeley and I thought to myself,
you're going to have to sell that to the,
to the department.
And I was right because after two years
I got an assistant professor offer from
Berkeley and if anybody ever tells you
that the law doesn't make a difference,
argue with them.
I also got an assistant professor
offer from the Stanford Business School
because although Stanford had not
had a complaint filed against them,
they were nervous that there might be one.
And so in 1972,
I was hired as the first
woman at the business school.
The first woman at the
law school was hired.
The first woman in engineering
was hired and on and on. So,
um, I, uh,
wound up teaching at
Stanford and not at Berkeley.
And I have had as one of my fields of
study all that time how partners can
balance family and careers.
Because as you see,
my experience at Berkeley was that they
didn't believe that I could possibly
balance a career, uh, at Berkeley
or presumably anywhere else.
Um,
and also have young children.
So what I wanna do now is talk about the
main issues that I see for people who
do want to balance two
careers, uh, and, and, uh,
a family too,
demanding careers and a family.
So let's take a look at these slides.
You can't have it all.
As an economist,
I'm always perplexed when
people ask me the question,
can you have it all kind of Mr into
tradeoffs? Nobody can have it all.
Something has to be traded off,
so you can have two demanding
careers and a family,
but something has to give.
Maybe it's no longer cooking five
gourmet meals a week or playing tennis or
exercising regularly or seeing
your friends as frequently,
but something is going to have to change.
However,
if two people are committed
to two careers and a family,
it's possible to achieve all of that if
they understand what they have to give
up in order to do that,
and if they're fully
committed to two careers,
what does it mean to be fully
committed to two careers?
It means that each spouse has to,
or partner,
has to be committed not
only to their own career,
but to the other career as well.
That's not easy and there are
challenges all along the way.
The most important career decision you're
going to make is not really a career
decision. It's about who you're
going to marry or partner with.
And if you're already married and,
uh, things are not working out well,
make sure you have a
conversation about this.
Make sure you understand what it's
about to be committed to two careers.
The first challenge is where are we going
to live and where are we going to work?
Um,
and the answer to these questions are
different for each couple because the
specifics are different.
So for example,
if one partner is much more
mobile than the other partner,
then that suggests that the couple should
locate where the person who needs more
mobility is,
uh,
should we take turns advancing our career?
You know,
should we move here and the first instance
for one career and then five years
later move, uh, for
another career move? Uh,
sometimes that works out well.
Sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes if you keep switching
careers and nobody has priority,
then you wind up with two
careers that aren't working well.
So you have to really think about
these issues. They're tough.
Should we choose only locations
where both people can flourish?
Usually that works well. And usually
that means a fairly large area.
So you know, the bay area, Los
Angeles, New York, Chicago,
Atlanta,
places where both members of a
couple can find jobs and move up.
Should we have a commuter
marriage? That's tough. Uh,
the literature seems to suggest that
a commuter marriage works for a while.
If it's time limited,
if both people know that it's not
going to last forever. And of course,
if there are children involved,
then a commuter marriage is really tough.
How about dividing housework
and home management?
While you may be able to outsource
a good deal of housework,
but unless you're extremely rich,
uh,
you and your partner will
be managing your home. Um,
how will you divide the management work?
People often forget about the
management function. You know,
they decide who's going to cook and
who's going to clean up, but they forget,
you know, somebody has to be involved
in who's going to call the plumber.
But somebody has to know that a
plumber has to be called. Okay.
Somebody has to know that you have to
sign up the kids for camp before all the
slots are filled.
Those are all management functions.
Are you going to be cozy CEOs or are
you going to divide up the function?
If you're going to be cozy Yos then you
have to have a lot of communication.
As is always the case when
there's more than one,
a CEO involved deciding
when and if to have a child.
Well from people always ask me when
is the best time to have a child?
The answer is that it's always the best
time and it's always the worst time.
Now, if you want a child, it's the
best time whenever you have a child.
But a child is likely to slow
your career to some degree.
And if you're both members of
the couple of sharing childcare,
then it may slow both careers.
So again,
this is a tough decision. How are
you going to care for your children?
Well, leaving the workforce
one, one member of the
couple leaving the workforce,
um, is one possibility.
Uh, and more and more, uh,
dads are leaving the workforce,
but that is a very costly decision.
The person who leaves the workforce,
uh,
generally loses a good deal of his or
her network unless they make a really
conscious effort to maintain that network.
Often their skills
depreciate unless again,
they make a very conscious effort
to keep those skills going.
And the literature shows that when
you come back, when women come back,
there's not enough men coming back
from childcare to, to study it yet,
but when women come back,
their earnings are permanently
lower by as much as 20%.
Now this could be because of the jobs
that they choose or because their new
bosses don't see them as good material
for promotion because they've taken time
out. But in any case, uh,
the combination of factors leads
to an earnings decrement. Also,
people lose insurance in case of divorce
because if you have to come back to the
workforce in case of divorce and you
haven't been in the workforce for a long
time, you're going to have a
lot of trouble getting back in
part time work is another
potential solution,
but often it's not a very good solution.
It can be the worst of all worlds because
often employers don't pay per hour.
What you would get if you had a
fulltime job. Benefits are often lower.
Uh, often employers don't
see people who work time,
part time as good
candidates for promotion.
And the other problem that people tell
me about all the time is that even though
they've negotiated a part time schedule,
they wind up working full time.
So now it is the worst of both worlds
because you're working full time but you
only have a part time salary.
So we are part time seems to work best
is when you've already been a full time
person and you negotiate for
part time in a limited way.
So you say, you know, I'm, I'm
coming back from having a child, um,
and I want to work part time
for the next six months.
Can we work that out so that,
that seems to be a good solution there.
Inform yourselves about
childcare options early.
Like when you know you're
going to have a child, uh,
because it's often difficult
to find good quality childcare.
And we know that good quality childcare
has been official to children.
Uh,
but not all childcare is good quality
and inform yourselves about what to look
for in terms of the quality of childcare.
Now people always talk about
balancing work and family,
but that could be not the ideal metaphor
because if you think of balance as,
you know, the scales of justice
with equality for most people,
work in family is not equal. You
know, for some work is higher,
but some families higher.
Um,
but it doesn't mean that the
balance has to be, you know,
equal.
Um,
I think the better notion
is the jar of life.
So figure out what things
in your life are the rocks,
what are the things I really should go
into that jar and put those things in
first.
So after the jars filled with rocks,
then the pebbles can all pebbles and the
sand can all fill in around the rocks.
But you know that you fit
in the most important stuff.
And I think in striving for balance,
it's probably fruitless to imagine that
you'll work in family life is going to
be in balance every day, every
week, maybe not even every month.
But what's important is that you both
continually work to move back into what
you decide is the right balance.
And I like to think about a
band of acceptibility. Okay,
so my work family is in
balance within this band.
And if I'm out here or
my family is out here,
then we agree that we got to get
back into our band of acceptability.
We've got to change
some things to get back.
So I liked that notion of work,
family balance rather than, uh,
the scales of equality. And
finally, let me just say that,
you know, work, family balance is
not just about you and your family.
Many of you are or will be in a
position to help other people,
to balance their work and family. And, uh,
when you make decisions
with your employees,
people who report to you about how they're
going to be able to balance work and
family, think about the
power that you have, uh,
to make their life more livable.
And also think about how we can jointly
put more flexibility into the entire
system.
As you probably know,
the United States is the
only industrialized country
without a paid leave for
maternity let alone paternity.
Uh,
we need to change that and
we have no childcare system.
The last time there was a bill in
Congress for a childcare system was 1971.
Nixon vetoed that bill and no
bill has come to Congress in sin.
So, uh, Hillary Clinton now has
a, a plan for a childcare system,
but it's been 45 years since congress
took up the notion of a childcare system
for the country.
So there's work to do obviously in your
own family and your workplace and in the
society as a whole.
Thank you.
I've always put about 30% on as the figure
for how much extra are family spends
that it wouldn't if one
parents stayed home full time.
And that's for house cleaning,
takeout,
guilt gifts for the kids.
Um,
is that an accurate figure? It
had. Do you got any stats on that?
I don't have stats on that,
but I think that as families
make decisions about
whether both parents should
work or not.
Um,
you don't want to make a decision
based on short run factors. So,
you know, what some people
do is they say, you know,
this is the salary that the second earner
could earn in the workplace and here's
what we have to pay for all the
factors you talked about childcare,
extra cleaning, takeout,
often an extra car.
Okay, so you know, does it pay?
Is My salary or the other person's salary
high enough to cover all those costs?
So I don't think that's a good way to
think about this because this is not a
short run issue.
This is a longterm issue.
And if you take into account
the decrease in salary,
that's going to take place when the
person who left the workforce comes back
then over a lifetime of,
well now lifetime but a work lifetime.
Um,
those childcare costs and guilt gifts.
And I love that.
Guilt gifts and extra cleaning and
whatever are going to be minimal.
It's really an economic investment to
pay for those things in order to keep a
person in the workforce,
keep those skills current,
keep those networks up and,
and get the income from the second person.
And also it's not a good idea
to think about, you know,
will the second person's salary cover
these expenses because really these are
family expenses and you don't want to
think about them as having the second
earner needing to cover those
expenses. You know, both,
both people are responsible.
Oh, I have a question. And uh,
around kind of the lean in
movement and having women who, uh,
you know, going on maternity leave,
coming back reporting into me,
everyone has different
experiences around it. Oh, for me,
I read the book of the very powerful time
when I had my first child and it kind
of inspired me to really come
back and come back full force.
But I have a lot of women who,
when we talk about it,
they feel that there's
almost double pressure.
So I've had a different experience.
I actually think the lean in movement
and all the research has been helpful in
my career on sticking with the workforce.
But there are people that report to me
that say it's put too much pressure on
them as women. I'm curious in your
research at Stanford and your engagement,
how you address it, and I know
it's not one size fits all right,
but ultimately how do you
respond to women that feel, God,
there's so much pressure to be amazing
moms to be fully full throttle into our
career as well.
So I think the point you make that
no one size fits all is the key.
And we have very interesting
discussions in my classes.
I teach a class at the Stanford business
school on work and family and 40% of
the students are men.
And some of them have had a fair amount
of work experience because they're back
for what used to be known at the
business school as the Sloan program.
Now it has some other name
ms x or something. Um,
and so a lot of those men are very proud
of the way in which they helped women
to handle, uh, coming back
to work after pregnancy.
And so they talk about what they did.
And invariably some woman
will raise her hand and say,
that's not what I want when I come back.
So your point that different
women want different things.
One woman will say, when I come
back, I want to be full force.
I don't want anybody
change my travel schedule.
I don't want anybody to change my,
uh, you know, number of meetings.
I want to be there full force.
And others will say what
some of your reports say, no,
I can't handle that right now.
I need to move over a little bit.
Uh,
take away some of my responsibilities.
And in a few years I'd like
to be able to move back.
That's the key. It used to be that
the so called Mommy track, you know,
tuck away responsibilities,
but then you were gone.
You were gone from the screen and
when you said you wanted to come back,
the answer was too bad for you.
You've missed the train, uh,
you can't get on that track anymore,
which is really a foolish way to think
about human resources and know you were
at for a few years. So now we're never
going to use your full force again. Uh,
but the manager really has to have a
conversation with the report to find out
what's what's desired. And the
second thing about that is, you know,
people can change their mind.
So you have that conversation before
the woman or even the man leaves for a
family leave and then they come back
and they have a different perception.
I mean,
so many things can happen.
They might have a child
with special needs. Well,
they didn't anticipate that when they
told you they wanted to come back full
force or they might find that their own
health is not as strong as they thought
it was going to be for whatever reason.
So yes,
it's good to have a conversation
before the person goes out on leave,
see what they're thinking.
But then the real key is to having a
conversation when they're ready to come
back.
And you know,
I think lean in is very important
because it says, you know,
try to do.
But I think Sheryl Sandberg's main
message is don't leave before you leave.
That's critical. You know, keep going
full force for as long as you can,
assuming your health is good.
Uh,
but I think that in a leaning
in is only part of the story.
I think that you need to have
employers who meet you halfway.
Otherwise,
I always tell my students,
if you keep leaning in and
nobody's there to meet you,
you're just going to fall over.
So that doesn't do anybody any good.
So yes,
you need to work hard,
but employers need to have
policies that meet people halfway.
I think that Deloitte has done a really
good job of trying to figure out how to
have lots of different paths after people
leave the workforce or come back part
time. Um, and then you know,
as they're ready to resume a full tilt,
then they're welcomed to do that.
I think that's really ideal is what
is a real world example of a band of
acceptability agreement a couple could
have in place in their relationship?
Well,
one,
one aspect of the band of acceptability
might have to do with how many nights a
week the family eats dinner together.
So,
you know, seven is one possibility,
but you might say, look,
it's fine if, um, you know,
one partner Mrs dinner with the family
one night a week and a second partner Mrs
dinner with the family.
So now the family is going to have
dinner five nights a week or maybe the
couple's going to go out for dinner
by themselves one night a week.
So now the family eats
together four nights a week.
When children get older,
that may be impossible.
Not because of the parents work scheduled
because of the kids' sports schedules.
No. So then you might say, okay,
every Sunday morning our family is going
to have a pancake breakfast together.
And that's, you know, nothing
can interfere with that.
So that would be a band of acceptability.
Or You could have,
um,
acceptibility rules about travel.
So how many nights a month is it
okay for one or the other partner,
uh, to be outside the city
in some other city? Okay.
Is it fine? Five nights a
week, four nights a week, um,
10 days a month,
whatever your family decides is right.
Then if things begin to move
toward more and more nights away,
you can sit down and say to one
another, wait a minute, look, this is,
this isn't what we said we wanted to do.
Something has to change here.
So that would be an example.
Um, it's common for working mothers
to be asked why they have children,
if their children will spend most of
their waking hours with someone else.
How do you think about the role of a
working parent and in particular how best
to measure your contribution
to your children?
If you can't win on quote unquote time,
although you may be away for
many of the child's waking hours,
you as a parent,
I'm going to be right there for other
of those working of those of the child's
hours. Uh, certainly on the
weekends, in the evening,
in the early morning.
Um,
and I think parents have a tremendous
effect on their children. Uh,
even if their children are in childcare
or if they are raised by a third parent,
like a grandparent or a nanny.
Um,
one of the interesting ways to think about
this is when a child is cared for not
only by his or her parents,
but also by another person and the
other person has a different accent.
The child picks up the parents accent.
So,
you know, over hundreds of years, uh,
English royal children were raised by
people who didn't necessarily have the
upper class English accent and somehow
or other those children figure out which
accent they're supposed to imitate.
And I think that's true
for not just language.
I think children know very
early who their parents are and,
um, the kind of love that they
get from those parents hopefully.
And there's a bond that isn't a created
by a nanny or child care worker or even
a grandparent. There's a different
kind of love with a grandparent.
So I think there's plenty of hours in
the week for to interact with their kids,
to show them they love
them. And, you know,
I'm just amazed all the time
by my students and former
students who talk about
ways in which they have created to
interact with their children even when
they're traveling. So now
we have Skype. I mean,
that's a phenomenal way to
be involved with your kids.
Before that we had phone
conversations. Um, so I,
I just think that children know who their
parents are and know the kind of love
that they get from those parents.
And you know,
also stu students tell me that when
they can't be at their child's a ballet
recital, they, uh,
have somebody there who videotapes it and
then they sit with the child and watch
the videotape and they say,
no,
that's even better than having been in
the audience because now we can stop the
tape. We can talk about what
the child was doing and feeling.
So I think with technology and with
a little bit of thinking about this
appearance can have very fruitful
relationships with their parents,
with their children,
even if they're working hard.
My question is about the body of
work available on this subject.
How much research is available
with children being the subjects.
There's a tremendous amount
of research available. Um,
my daughter in law,
Joanna Strober and a coauthor Sharon
mirrors have a book called, uh,
getting to 50, 50,
which was published. Um,
I think 2009 maybe.
Um,
and that has a review of the
research up to that time, uh,
from BF for beyond that really you
can go onto the internet and find a
tremendous amount of research
if you want to. You know,
Google scholar is terrific
on this, uh, to find the,
the serious journal articles,
but also government publications.
There's just an enormous amount
of stuff out there. Too much.
It's hard to sift through it.
It's kind of gray area where men,
they're not leaning out,
it's not the primary caregiver,
but they are put potentially taking a
little bit of a valley and their career to
support potentially a woman,
their partner who's really full force.
It could be a new job, it could
be a move. And just the way is,
as society evolved enough to accepted and,
and it comes from a personal example.
I've moved from New York for this
Google position. It's a very big job.
My husband's kind of leaning
in and supporting me and
he, he, it's interesting,
he shares with me, he's still
working. He's running his business,
but it's not the New York base and
a lot of parents in school and just,
he does more of the dropoffs kind
of always hint to him like, Hey,
when are you going to get back in
when you, and he's like, I'm in,
I'm just not in at 120% like Molina
is right now because Google's new,
it's intense.
It's interesting as gray area that
maybe people don't want to talk about.
And I'm curious if you see
when the men are kind of
supporting their wives,
but then society thinks that they've
completely leaned out. I Dunno.
It's just curious.
I think it's really tough for men who
are trying to make these changes because
they do get those kinds
of comments. Um, and they,
they have to be not only strong
in terms of their career,
they have to be strong and
facing all these other,
usually mothers who have all these,
uh,
words about what they should and
shouldn't be doing. And, you know,
I've often thought it'd be fun
to have a class for men who are,
as you say, uh, leading in
a, to support their wives,
to give them some comments that they
might offer in return for these negative
comments about, um, you know, when are
you going to get back in and so on. Um,
you know, I, I just think that
whenever you're a pioneer,
you have to face these societal norms,
uh,
that haven't changed yet. And in my
book, uh, sharing the work, you know,
I was a pioneer.
I was the first woman at the Stanford
Business School and the book is filled
with these kinds of discussions
about what I had to face.
Now the pioneers are people like your
husband who are really bucking the trends,
um, and are saying, no,
my wife has gotten a great job at
Google and I'm going to support her.
And she's going all the way
and I'm still staying in,
but I'm doing more childcare
than I might've done otherwise.
And um, you know, I think you have to,
you have to be a pioneer
and you have to be strong.
Can you talk about challenges taking
care of aging parents and family members
and any nuances to what you've covered
with regard to partnering balance on this
top?
Sorry.
With regard to partnering slash balance
on this topic versus childcare balance?
That's a really important question.
Um,
I didn't have a section on elder
care in my work family course,
uh,
until maybe seven or eight years ago when
one of the men in my class did a paper
on elder care.
And at the bottom of his paper he said,
I think this topic should be in the
class. And I thought to myself, yes,
it's really should. And so since that
time we do have the topic in the class.
And in many ways elder care is
more challenging than childcare.
I mean,
even though children may be rebellious,
basically the parents are in charge,
you know,
the parents make the decisions and you
know, try to get the children to go along.
That's not true with elder care.
Adult children are not in charge
of their parents, adult children.
I have to wait for the appearance,
make decisions that they can support.
They can try to influence them.
But the parents are in charge.
The other thing is that,
you know, children grow up.
So childcare is only for a few years
and then they become teenagers,
which is a whole different story.
But you know,
then they stopped being teenagers and
they grew up more with elder care.
You don't know how long your
parent is going to need care.
Um,
you don't know whether the situation's
going to get better or more likely worse.
Um,
it's much less predictable.
They often don't live in the
same city where you live.
And the statistics seem to show that
more days are lost from work by adults
doing elder care.
Then childcare because childcare is
predictable so you can line up help,
but elder cares,
particularly if you have to go to another
state to take care of your parent is
not predictable.
And I think elder care is still not
talked about much in the workplace.
A lot of people don't want their manager
to know that they're involved in elder
care because they're spending a
lot of time at work doing this.
And so I believe this is the topic
for the future with regard to work,
family balance and you know if there's
an emergency with your parents,
there is no balance.
None at all. You know,
150% of your time and effort is involved
in trying to deal with this emergency.
And then you have to make
all the other arrangements,
especially if you're in the cell called
sandwich generation where you not only
have elder parents but
you have young children.
So then you're really running from one
to the other to try to get the balance
that you need.
Interestingly,
more and more studies show that men
are more involved in elder care.
So it used to be when wives or at home
and not in the workplace that they did
the elder care, not only for their parents
but also for their husbands parents.
But that's not so true anymore.
So more and more men are doing the
care for their own parents and um,
really stepping up to
that. So again, that's a,
that's a whole new sort of pioneering.
Can you give any guidance on the proper
timing and method to start speaking with
your manager about your decision
to start family planning?
So I think this idea of when you
should talk to your manager also,
uh, is very specific.
Um, they're very, this,
this specifics of the
situation are really important.
If you know that your manager
is going to be helpful,
um, and isn't going to say
to you something like, oh,
why you go and do that,
you could have had a great career,
then you might want to talk
to your manager early on.
If you think your manager is
not going to be supportive,
you might want to wait a little bit
more before you talk. But you know,
pregnancy has a way,
particularly for women of showing,
so your manager's going to find
out at some point or other,
and it's probably better if you talk to
your manager before he or she can see
that you're pregnant.
Um,
and so I think the best example I know
is a former student of mine who was in
strategic planning at a tech company.
This was years ago.
And she went into her
manager early on and said,
this is the plan.
This is the strategic
plan for my pregnancy and,
and, uh, childbirth.
So here is a flow chart and here's what
I'm going to be doing for the next six
months.
And then I want to take some time off and
I'm going to check in at each of these
points. And then after, you know, six
months, I'm coming back full time.
Um,
and she said,
you can't find anybody to do this job
better than I can given the strategic plan
I just gave you. And he
sort of said, bless you.
Uh, so you know, if you say what you
want and how are you going to do it?
And you're confident and
of course everybody has to
understand that things might
not quite work out that way depending
on what happens. But you know,
you can say with 90% confidence perhaps
that this is what is going to happen.
Here's what we're going to do.
I was wondering if you could share some
of your suggestions for how to make that
dip in a career for,
you know,
a couple to young professionals with
let's say six relatively successful
[inaudible] when I took your class,
I remember when you talked to about
one suggestion which was hiring a night
nanny even though it's quite expensive,
but there's actually quite
a lot of benefit of getting
a good night's sleep for
both partners and then having a more
productive day and the psychological.
So I was hoping to get a
refresher on things like that.
Well of course, you know, if you have, um,
a lot of money, then there are lots
of solutions like a night nanny.
Um,
if you are not in such a
great financial situation,
then of course you're more limited
and you have to be more creative.
When I see graduate students at Stanford
who by definition do not have a lot of
money. Well unless their parents
have a tremendous amount of money,
but they don't have a lot of money.
They use a co op method.
So they went when they want to go out
to a movie or they want to go out for
dinner a date night or something,
they probably won't go out for a movie.
But you know, for four out for
dinner, just the two of them. Um,
instead of hiring a babysitter, which
can cost you no more than the dinner,
um, they will trade off.
So they'll say, you know,
tonight we're going to go out for dinner.
You Watch both your children
and mine and then, you know,
tomorrow night you go and I'll watch you.
It,
I think there's lots of
ways of cooperating with
other people who also have
young children that work out
very well. Even, you know,
would you take my child,
uh,
for the afternoon so I can get a nap
if your child's not napping anymore,
otherwise try to nap when the job
maps in it. Good thing. But, um,
you know,
I think your question is wonderful because
it shows you that you have to think
creatively about how to do this.
You know,
it was easier in the old days where you
had lots of family living around you and
you could just drop your kid off for a
few hours with somebody in your family.
Now you have to arrange those kinds of,
of um,
new family arrangements with,
with people who are actually no friends
by choice rather than family members.
But truly if you,
if you have a lot of money,
I mean I know people who hire
more than one nanny, you know,
some nanny comes,
you know,
from eight to six and another
nanny comes from five to nine and,
and then if the child is a newborn
and not sleeping through the night,
they might hire a night nurse.
So all of those things are
possible for a very few people.
So this is sort of adding on to the
Koa question, but how important it is,
it is it to have a network of women,
not your job,
but when she come back that are sort of
experiencing the same experiences as you
are? Well, I don't think
it's necessarily, um,
necessary to have it at your job. Uh, uh,
some women prefer to have a network of
women doing the same thing they're doing,
but at other companies so
that they can be, you know,
100% frank about what's going on and
not worry that somebody is at their own
workplace.
Other people like to have a
network at their workplace,
but no matter how you slice it,
a network is key.
I know when I was raising my kids,
there were very few
professional women and, uh,
my network consisted of my kids'
friends' mothers at their nursery school.
So they, they weren't professional women
at all, but they were so helpful to me,
uh, in, in so many ways. Um, no.
If my babysitter couldn't come
because she had a family emergency,
I would call one of them. And they
would take my children home with them,
you know, at lunchtime. And um, you,
you can't do this just by yourself.
And of course,
the luckiest thing is if you can get your
parents to move to near where you are
or you move back.
I mean,
I had a student who she and her husband
moved back to Shanghai because that's
where their parents were and they could
not imagine doing this kind of thing
without their parents help. So, you know,
the geographic location had nothing to
do with their two careers and had to do
with where their parents were.
Thank you so much. You're welcome.